this is a king's topic and um yeah want
be this I'll set him up yeah set it up
please yes Starfield y' Starfield um
huge huge uh debut huge numbers coming
back wins MPD I got I gotta stop say MD
shirana right it's the the new the worst
I hate s mama name him MPD I'mma call
him
MPD it's still MPD to me it's it's like
Twitter and X to me it's still Twitter
exactly so shout out Twitter X baby
shout out to Matt piscatella from the r
we've had him in Imagine hit someone up
and like yo you got that X
subscription yo
whoa but uh yeah Starfield was the best
selling game of September instantly
becoming the seventh bestselling game of
2023 year to date Starfield seventh yeah
from the whole year Starfield for that
crazy yeah that is crazy Starfield Zelda
came out right yes Zelda came out a lot
of games came out this the ton this you
we're saying that this is the best year
in gaming and this made it to the
seventh and it just came out word just
came out yes St sofield ranked as the
bestselling title of the month across
Xbox and PC PC being it leag uh sales
platform um I want to get how much you
sold on
Playstation it did not sell on
Playstation it won't ever sell over
there this is this is this is why will
never this is why if you wonder why we
don't get
codes this could a factor some of us are
trying to be journalists here whereas
some of us are trying to be
provocators so y'all are saying they're
picking and choosing I for one not being
a journalist I I've accepted our role in
the industry at this
pointed I am a villain you created the
role I've accepted it like it fell in
your lap like you didn't do nothing
for you deserve it I resent
that so please let Cog finish again for
again just want to go over September is
again top top 20 games uh for the month
of September this is based on dollar
sales excludes add all content new was
Starfield number one from Microsoft
number two Mortal Kombat 1 which was
also new EA Sports FC formerly known as
FIFA number three number three number
four Madden and still in football season
y'all NFL 24 payday three number five
broken for broke it for a month payday
three was up there it's networking was
was I I talked to someone behind the
scenes they said that the reason it
worked so well for the game pass
literally like destroyed their Network
like they didn't expect the amount of
people they didn't expect us to show up
because we play games oh no they showed
up they showed up so much that every
they would stabilize the network
andash again cuz we play games let's go
fade A3 was number five number six the
new to the list and The Perennial f
usually all the time NBA K 2K 24 oh you
said Starfield B 2K Starfield B 2K now
in defensive 2K digital sales they
didn't have a v-bucks up they digital
the only thing is that's all physical
for 2K um no digital sales was included
for 2K too bad you get judged okay
number seven which we all reviewed and
played the crew motorest makes his debut
cuz I actually felt like that was a
drastic improvement from previous uh I
didn't think the crew was going to be
big old star
yeah let's go then number eight rounding
out the uh we got armor core 6 it was uh
number eight this month number two that
game just recently came out like last
mon it was number two last B look it's
still strong Hogwarts Legacy at number
nine number one overall yeah we going to
get I'm going to get to that list I'm
going get to that list yep you're right
and it was number five last month and
riding out the top 10 was Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 the 2022 version and U
wait so it was no PlayStation games and
no Nintendo games in well
um yeah nintend they not in the top 10
if we're talking top 10 no Talking Top
10 bro yeah top 10 no it's it's
Starfield number one Mortal Kombat EC
yeah and then I want to round out the
well where you going to be next month
when Spider-Man's at the top listen
listen listen listen let's let's cross
that bridge when we get to
it I know I know Spider-Man won't be
there he won't be number one but I know
who still be in the top 10
wants to do a bend the knee on this but
you don't want your knees gone stop it
you do safe stuff you do safe stuff my
you do safe stuff this is dangerous for
you stay yeah it is a little dangerous I
feel I am shaking a little on my boots
right final stat and then I'll give it
over to King again year to date ending
in 2023 and again top 10 bestselling
premium games dollar sales excluding
add-on content for the year now for the
entire year from now to September um hog
WS Legacy like s said number one hogw
Legacy wow Legend canel game the canel
oh yeah the cancel legy number two
Legend of Zelda taser Kingdom but I got
to give the Nintendo base this does not
include digital sales damn so there's a
strong chance that Zelda tear of the
Kingdom could be number one I I have to
give Zelda they flowers on that number
three Madden already NFL 24 number you
know how Madden do yeah man number four
for jez Cordon Diablo 4 number can I get
a Diablo 4 pronunciation from everyone
everyone hates on blizzard right but
everyone secretly plays blizzard games
where my blizz hey no we asked for a
Diablo prod we I need a Dia asked for
that we need a Diablo yes there we go no
you got to say you have to say beta with
it you have to say beta with it always
beta dude like for for the last like
37 years I've been calling it Diablo
that's right that it sound it sounds
refine when you say that Diablo for
beta gorgeous it's gorgeous I just see
that that meem where it
say let's let Co finish please okay he's
ready to cook um Call of Duty
something's going on yeah something's
going on Call of Duty another Activision
Blizzard game at Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 of the 2022 version number uh
number five rounding out number six Star
Wars Jedi Survivor at number six and new
to the list in one month for the whole
year to date is Starfield debuting at
number seven in one month number eight
notice how they have the they have the
publisher
Microsoft not yeah not yeah cuz we own
they own now
baby no no we paid money for you sit
up pay like she made and then eight
Mortal Kombat 1 for the years so Mortal
Kombat still did well but consider it
debuted as well number nine Resident
Evil 4 from Capcom and rounding out
which is very interesting s MLB The
show3 Wait so there's no PlayStation
games how many times we have to say no
yo wait wait this is the second list
buddy there is there is Technic G
PlayStation game there let's not me
which one which one though I'm trying to
the game would not yes M mo the show is
multiplatform it's on switch it's on
switch
G it is developed by
PlayStation on the list it says publish
of multiple video game
manufacturer I'm just what tell it's not
Sony that's not son it goes in G that's
our first listen that's a first party
studio for it is not you know what king
yes I I approve that message that was
messy they they in date for
us so K this is your your topic I know
you've been chopping at the bit what is
your thought Starfield has done it
f what is going
Oni has done it I told y'all I told y y
talking about glitching and moving and
Starfield they don't buy no games
Starfield will sell Starfield won't be
this so you tried to you tried to
sabotage us
like
Planet he look like a bootleg gotcha
man that rock is still lifted off that
rock is still with his face ah he we b
game hold up hold up the dude that does
the fan art I want King on a rocket with
that
with don't put him on like a rocket like
a witch we not do it that's
disrespectful this right I say this
y'all say that uh oh with his hands up
say I I want to see him taking that off
though that's yeah that's going to be
interested so so so you dudes you dud
said game pass with candle Biz games o
Game Pass uh will inite people not to
buy
games Game Pass Game Pass is the problem
Microsoft is devaluing their first party
games by putting it over there cuz
nobody's going to buy
them seventh in sales and it just came
out
out number one in
MPD Boy watch your
mouth watch your mouth now a lot of you
dudes like to say oh they won't even
nominate Starfield for Game of the Year
first month came out bro NPD beat Madden
beat all these dudes beat big 2K what's
up
man Sals it's sold what's up M yeah
that's huge who we talking about we we
in space of what are we going to space
or what what we doing here what we doing
here there ain't nothing I can say to
Top This he his bag he his back I'm I'm
I'm I'm sick and tired of you guys
trying to sit there and poke holes in us
talking about y'all won't do this and we
keep proving every we
will yo big star feeli is
outside and y'all are terrified could
you imagine once it gets nominated for
Game of the Year all y'all gonna start
crying oh how they get nominated with
all those bugs shut up Spider-Man got
bugs
too shut
up we're at the point now we're at the
precipice we at The Changing of the
Guard oh look oh JZ is hating from this
side Diablo better oh with this F that's
that's nice we own them
too they they in Pocket too that was a
perfect clapback that was a perfect CL
FL back I even going for what's funny
man like J sitting there trying to get
that Spirit Bomb and and King's like we
on that to yeah that's right diffuse
that right there put that over there
when that being Game Pass it'll probably
really do some numbers anyway oh my Lord
let's go we them I told dudes what
Starfield was going to do you laughed at
me I am 98% right all the
time y'all in trouble this is the time
where trouble is happening Phil Dominus
Maximus aelia Spencer has turned into
Sith lord phield it's over just said
Starfield wasn't G to do what it's going
to do and I said I can't wait for mpds
and he was like yo King are you sure you
want to hear that when it comes out yo
Matt you my man love you to death you
about Matt bis can tell her now okay
okay I got you I been about Matt I've
been about Matt but see I listen it's
going to be a point in time CU Microsoft
G on everything
so it's cuz see y'all y' talk about
y'all was mad at us when they said what
they going to acquire
next we literally was just talking about
it earlier they were saying well
strategically we said this strategically
we should go get square square will burn
your life to the ground y all y'all
dudes that heard Square was like no no
no get SGA
please please please oh God no get S
please cuz you know if they go get
square what happens to you
next y'all are ready in
disar I will say that if they ever
bought Square Enix it would be really
bad for PlayStation really fast it'd be
curtains curtains I don't know about
curtain
curtains listen Spaceman King signing
off with number one in npds number seven
in Sals that means it's sold that means
we buy
stuff and don't tell me the PC sold the
most because there's PC game pass over
there too so they could have just said
nah I don't even want to buy it shut up
there's no excuses for you dudes no more
well for for three week sperman better
come in it better beat Mario for for
three weeks King it was the number one
most sold thing on on on Xbox and it was
over Madden all that stuff for like
three
weeks most play right who who who
thought it would come in number one in
NPD no I didn't think I didn't think
that I mean I mean we'll talk I'll get
to my I got to get jez you know what I'm
saying I guess go ahead then jez man
this is this who's that guy yeah who's
that guy you know say Lord jez space man
king baby I don't remember drinking this
popular
cure so Lord JZ what do you make of this
Starfield you know winning MPD excuse me
or Sakana you know seventh you know
overall year to date you know how do you
extrapolate the data what what's your
thoughts on this cuz there was a lot of
narratives coming in to this about you
know game passing effect on titles what
I can't really follow up from King man
king king's wearing a NASA NASA uniform
bro so it's kind of like King said it
all man it destroys the narratives of
Game Pass impacting CES and it kind of
it dovetails back into what I said
earlier though Microsoft uses
Metacritic as or the industry uses
Metacritic as an indicator of what'll do
well what I'll do well in Game Pass
what'll do well in retail sales will do
well on social media and all that kind
of stuff you know and um Bethesda has a
legacy a fan base that's established
dating back decades man and it's the
kind of it's the I remember when I first
started in this business and the
blogging business or whatever and the
first event I ever went to was uh
Gamescom
2015 2016 I can't remember off the top
of my head but I met Aon Greenberg at
that show and he was like what feedback
do you have for us and I was like Bro
you've got to you've got to lean into
Nostalgia more man you've got lean into
into Nostalgia more cuz you know
PlayStation's out here with Nostalgia
Nintendo's out here with Nostalgia and
you know you you sort of Xbox doesn't
really have that s besides like Halo Age
of Empires flight simulator and to a
lesser extent Gears of War which is more
more recent really Gears of War is more
recent um they don't really have that
sort of Legacy that some of the studios
enjoy but that's what they've purchased
with zenimax and that's what they
purchased with blizzard is that sort of
Legacy that Legacy fan base people who
sort of our age we're all getting old
all of us getting old but we've got a
lot of money to spend you know more so
than a than a kid or a teenager or some
of us anyway like I remember when I was
in my early 20s and I'd have to be i' be
kind of like [__] should I buy this
should I buy that but you know as you
get older you get raises and you get
more money and people in their 30s and
4S generally have higher purchasing
power at least in yes you know Western
economies or whatever so like like it's
that kind of that fan base you need to
Target and that's kind of what they
bought with zenimax and Beth blizzard
right they've bought a legacy they've
bought a fan base uh they've bought
people who are our age with purchasing
power potentially and that is heavily
reflected in franchises like Diablo
heavily reflected in franchises like
Starfield because even though starfields
a new IP it's still a Bethesda game
absolutely at its core it's a pure pure
as gold Bethesda yes experience you know
so yeah it's pretty exciting to think
like what will happen when they actually
it's a Bethesda game but it's not a new
what happen when it's Elder Scrolls what
happen when it's Fallout five you know
good point it's going to be really
exciting to see that blow up because a
lot a lot of normies normies they don't
know what Starfield is but tell them
like the the next Skyrim's coming out or
tell them the next for coming out then
it's going to have it's going to have an
even bigger impact so I think it's it's
exciting for the future of Xbox
particularly when you can the AL Scrolls
in Fallout 5 will be exclusive to the
brand
and it seems to have been reflected in
console sales too right yeah yeah yeah
number seven it's exciting man it's
exciting but Diablo is still
better there no problem I mean I want
them to sell too no salute to to jez and
what he's saying and I didn't even think
about I didn't even think about that you
know from the you know was they number
one in their month they came out who
Diablo yeah I don't remember I don't
remember the last couple nobody heard it
doesn't matter man it's still bad what I
wanted to say was that I do want double
up chess made a fantastic point in
reference to that this is a new IP from
Bethesda but like you said that Bethesda
Legacy that Heritage it being you know a
western RPG and people still showed out
so it it really bolds well for the
established franchises right the the
fallouts the Elder Scrolls that people
will will more likely maybe even flock
more because they really familiar with
those titles but I wanted to ask just
this before we move on what do you think
about the you know obviously we we heard
about the narrative with the you know
cannibalizing sales kind of thing but I
wanted to ask you about day and date PC
and in the PC portion of this like what
do you get from that data you know with
that PC also helped drive this this
whole this month well I was actually
thinking about this today like because
because I have no life and I'm
constantly thinking about what can I
what can I what can I create content out
of and you know one of the things I was
thinking about was like what would it
look like what would what would it look
like in a world west Starfield was a
timed a timed exclusive to Xbox consoles
right where where they do the
PlayStation model where it's like the
the game launches best and first on the
console and then it rolls out to PC many
years after the fact and me and ran
talked about this on the show the other
day where it was like we with in the
context of Final Fantasy 16 where it was
like um in Final Fantasy 16 is kind of
like um if fin fantasy 16 had launched
on PC and Xbox at the same time I feel
like it would have had a much stronger
presence on social media it would have
had a much stronger marketing viral
viral marketing push and Word of Mouth
push it would have been stronger on
Twitch as well because most twitch
streamers are on PC right at the end of
the day um
so but then for Starfield it's kind of
like it's it's a different model because
Square Enix doesn't care about pushing
console sells but Xbox Xbox should care
about pushing console sales because they
they are being hammered by Sony and to a
less
and and well not to a lesser extent at
all like Nintendo as well and you know
even though people people have this
debate about whether Xbox is in
competition with Nintendo and it I'm
sorry but unless you've got like four
arms you can't hold two controllers at
the same time either you're playing on
nendo system or you're playing on
PlayStation or you're playing on PC or
playing on Xbox at the same time there's
there's only so much attention you can
give to a specific platform at any one
time right so of course they're in
competition so it's kind of like what is
the V is there sort of like is there
value for Xbox to have made that console
exclusive to push console sales and of
course like the raw monetization
suggests that yeah it's better on PC
because they get the software sales and
the business is selling software it's
not necessarily selling consoles but
from like uh looking more further into
the
future having more developers in your
ecosystem is he's going to be more
sustainable for the Xbox platform and
you know if if game like Starfield could
have drove more Xbox sales um that
potentially armed to the Xbox platform
the fact that the that it is
simultaneously launching on PC yeah that
being said I think there's there's the
real the real real the real situation is
the fact that not everyone can afford a
high NPC and starfields system
starfields minimum recommended specs was
were not exactly um should we say I
don't know
friendly yeah yeah and you look at look
at the look at the minimum requirements
for Alan Wick like my my laptop is it's
a few years old now I've got an RTX 27
ETI in this thing and I am just within
the minimum the minimum specs for alen w
2 wow you know so like I'm kind of like
I now I need to upgrade my laptop I
spent three grand on this goddamn laptop
when it launched you know and um so now
it's like you know now I need to
consider upgrading my laptop if I want
to keep keep up the PC game gam is faere
or I can buy a PS5 or an Xbox series X
which is vastly orders of magnitude
cheaper or even a series X you know
because Alan W too has to run on that as
well although it'll be interesting to
see how see how it goes right yeah yeah
so Arguments for both right um but yeah
I I don't know we'll see we'll see I I
hear where you're coming from brother
and I totally hear what you're saying in
terms of the bet that they they took and
you know the decision as far as people
were saying like how are they going to
survive with Starfield not being on a
PlayStation platform so I think it is a
significant you know deal for them their
analytic teams and and the metrics to
see how this thing perform I want to get
I know adct jumped away for a little bit
but we'll get solv you know once add
comes back you know Starfield being
number one like did you see this coming
you know how do you feel about it you
know where do you sit with Starfield
winning
MPD I mean kind of new is coming man
like
it's it it's the followup to Skyrim from
Todd Howard it's going to sell it's
going to sell it's that type of game
that people could say what they want to
say online people could say oh whatever
gay pass I don't want to know G I don't
want to get in the subscription servers
I don't want this they gave you all
types of options to purchase this game
the game is available on Steam which is
where I played it um Game Pass if you
want to wait and if you don't want to
wait it's still available on Game Pass 5
days early just give me $35 that was a
huge the constellation Edition before
people p for that that's huge and that's
going to be huge moving forward for all
first party games oh you want Early
Access give us $30 give us 30 give us
$40 season pass give us something give
Early Access there you go there you go
and that money's going to come in that
way but it's to follow it's a new IP
from the team that gave you Oblivion
Fallout and Skyrim people are going to
buy people are going to buy I don't know
if this metric holds true for other
first party stuff coming down the line
maybe some like a if a fable blows the
doors off you know off the house or
something like that or
but yeah I just knew I just it was
anything to me it's because it's it's
it's too big you be listen people could
say whatever they want you know that the
game is it's a different type of Todd
Howard game right doesn't have the same
feeling of a Skyrim that whole idea of
oh I I look over there I can go over
there and it's going to be right you
know I agree with the criticism about
the game and that jumping from planet to
planet makes it feel a little more
disjointed and not like this whole this
entire world right I get that I get that
and I and I agree with it also at the
same time like again it was as long as
this game was good and it functioned and
it wasn't this this this train wreck and
trash fire at launch that people could
hold on to you know you couldn't it was
going to do well cuz even the people
online hating we're going to get this
game because they wanted it to be
good like you know what I mean like it's
or they wanted it to be bad so that that
they were G to get the game anyway to
try to purch the right exactly you know
exactly this is
content and the fact of the matter is
like this is kind of only the start
because I think when it comes to these
types of games from from from Todd's
team these games have a long tail like
you know when you start thinking about
what the mod Community is going to do
with this and what they're going to turn
this game into that's a fact like you
you're going to see this game on this
list probably for a while you know it'll
it it'll taper off then it'll come back
it'll taper off it'll come
back you're saying so he make
generational games yeah this is a game
this is a game that you still be talking
about if they do the right thing with it
right because to me it's all about the
community right and if the community
that has followed Fallout Oblivion and
and sky it continues to follow this game
then yeah it's going to be there it's
going to it's absolutely going to be
there and we may have a situation where
it's like oh they you know you're you're
playing Starfield on your refrigerator
on your sto or whatever you was was
those games you mentioned game of the
year when they came out I don't recall
Skyrim I'm assuming was I don't maybe
fall I don't remember what about
Oblivion I don't recall oh I don't
recall this guy right here man now now
everybody now now every body's
independent but all right no I mean we
know I Mis I misr okay no I love
Starfield I love Starfield it Ain Game
of the Year it's it's gonna be Game of
the Year this year we we paid the right
people we paid the right
people the iron Lords does not endorse
this message the rest of the Lords do
not cond the words agree all with the
words of King
DAV op you you want information on your
show you know what you got to do all
right fair enough fair enough Contin I'm
sorry yeah but to me when you look at
you know how long people been waiting
for the next game from from Todd's team
and it's a brand new IP the curiosity is
g to get you right even if you have a
disdained for Game Pass and Xbox or
whatever you as the moment they offered
on other platforms you were GNA you to
get this game so um yeah it doesn't
really surprise me a whole lot um I
expected it unless the again unless the
game was a trash fire and maybe even
then like I said the the content draws
people to try to you know to make videos
about negative stuff right so hey even
even then it might have sold super well
so yeah not I'm not surprised at all
I'll jump in until gets back um look I
got to be real I ain't expected to win
not that I didn't was going to do well I
knew it was going to do well but I was
thinking top five but to me that would
have been a victory cuz I'm looking at
the competition and look I've been
watching sfi's not going to win man no
not game of the year not game of the
year I'm talking about MPD I I knew Jaz
like I was like in my mind I'm like look
it's on Game Pass yes is exclusive it's
Todd's biggest IP you know from the main
team in a long time it's going to do
well it's going to be in that top three
to five right but I'm looking at the
month and I am a Mortal Kombat guy and
this Mortal Kombat one is phenomenal and
Mortal Kombat I know it's a fighting
game I heard you jzz you like it's a
fighting I know but historically they've
done pretty well for themselves and I
always looked at it as you got that and
then you know in America you know we're
football guys Madden but we are not
going to disrespect the artist formerly
known as as FIFA right like we are not
well FIFA I already bu pronounced it see
you can tell I'm American Michelle
fer Michelle Fifer Michelle
Fifer we go we Adidas Adidas with f you
go Adidas
and Adidas man exactly excuse my
American call we we say Adidas Adidas
Adidas you got to buy some ofas from the
store don't American clown me but um now
that was funny but uh yeah like I'm
looking at that I'm like that is an
absolute beast and we're still in
football season for Madden like this is
Madden y'all like we're not going to act
like like these are not Juggernauts and
here's the main indictment to me of how
impressive this is Starfield all these
other games are Co-op
multiplayer
microtransaction Starfield is single
player Western RPG to its core no micro
no transac none of that Co-op that can
boost engagements for free right tell
them tell them so the fact that this
showed me that there is a desire for the
traditional Western RG talkad I just
want to say one thing please please do
none of those games launched a Game Pass
where you was able to get it for free
without purchasing so what it showed me
goad tell what it showed me is people
wanted Starfield and they CED it
diffused all these narratives about Game
Pass catabolizing sales um supporting
the devs uh launching on PC devaluing
your launch it did not so we got to give
flowers where it is is that that's my
only thing it's like at the end of the
day when this is the thing I will say
about bias you know when PlayStation
does this thing and God of War and it
like bro we give it up yo bro that is
tremendous what I I I'm not seeing the
love for Starfield or how amazing this
accomplishment is in my opinion maybe
you know I'm in the wrong circles I'm
not on social media enough or whatever
but I will say and y'all going to like
the poll is that an adct might
appreciate this what this showed me
though in regards social media it it is
an echo chamber because the people spoke
the people said no no no the people with
the wallets the people like Jess whoever
they said we are buying Bethesda game
we're buying Stu we're excited this is a
good game and we're enjoying it and we
wanton it that's what this showed me
that is a huge deal and here's the other
thing about Mortal Kombat where people
are sleeping Mortal Kombat launched on
almost all platforms and was on switch
so Starfield still had a disadvantage
versus Mortal Kombat and in Game Pass if
you call that switch Port all right we
ain't gonna talk
about it did it did launch on
Playstation where well what they don't
buy games over there right and and the
talk was if Starfield how would
Starfield going to make up for the sales
without having PlayStation that was the
talk look at them they they did it
without you without you baby we this is
huge I can't I got to give King flowers
on this this is a huge internal data
point from Microsoft to prove their
Vision as far as now the key thing I'm
curious jez is Game Pass subscriptions
did that increase you know the UK I'm
not sure about you know also the console
stuff like that it also showed me what
Sol saying the constellation Edition
people are willing to pay early people
on PC willing to play on Steam like and
the last thing I'll say and this is the
thing to me when people always clown
Xbox they say remember when Xbox was
popping over they was like yo 1 million
then they were like or 6 million playing
Star field and let's be honest a lot of
people and pundants roll their eyes yeah
6 million people played whatever
whatever you know what I'm saying and
remember we used to roll our eyes
sometimes when they used should say that
by Starfield I mean um about SE a thev
did you see where sea of thieves was on
the Year date did you did you see a TF
thieves is on the year toate sales for
the year a game that people I didn't
know that bro I C SE thieves is in the
top 20 of two of year date hold on one
second that is I'm sorry excuse me
actually no no no no let me let me
correct that hold on one
second that is no I'm sorry I apolog
that is we're looking at September
2023 top 20 bestselling premium game for
the month of September SC I could be
correct that cfd is in that category so
cfd still made this m in top 20 and that
that's an older game I think this is
impressive y'all that was a broken game
in lunch right well it didn't have a
kraken Kraken didn't have a body right
it still doesn't have a body it's it
wasn't a broken game it just had it was
anic it was cont the millions of people
love it right and what I will say is to
addict's point you know Final Fantasy
and now we talk about for the whole year
right Starfield debuting in one month is
over Final Fantasy 16 over Resident Evil
4 over Street Fighter 6 an amazing
Street Fighter yes yeah did Final
Fantasy 16 win MPD that month that they
came out I don't remember the old mpds
bro I got I don't know I back I know I
know but I'm going to find out this
information because I got a lot more
bars no I feel listen this is my last
bar I'm move on someone in the chat look
that up for us thank you this is the
thing and I tell people all the time
when people laugh at Microsoft I know
listen Microsoft needs to be more
transparent with the numbers I'm not
saying they are okay fair enough so um
Microsoft needs to more more transparent
with their numbers subscri we're always
on them with that but I remember saw
people would always roll their eyes at
Microsoft whenever they say we've got 3
million active users and people like
what does that mean right and then they
were popping off with 6 million for star
people like well it doesn't we shouldn't
be popping bottles yet we need to see to
me a key metric what I'm noticing with
them and what I look personally is daily
active users monthly active users go to
Xbox most played and adct remember these
days cuz we're Destiny guys and people
were clown and say oh Destiny it's it's
terrible game but you would look in the
top 10 of Xbox most play look at that
category
when I used to see Starfield in the top
two to top three with the likes next to
Call of Duty next to fortnite these Mega
engagement games that mostly are free to
play and a single player game is right
there going head-to-head that is
tremendous as of right now it still
hasn't fallen out of the top 10 it's in
top it's like number six I believe most
played right now people are playing this
game this is tremendous and again I have
to sayate it again single player no
Co-op no no multiplayer no freeo play no
microtransaction no
PlayStation you're
ridiculous but we don't need
y'all